hello and welcome to this video playing
Joe floor Joe slow yeah only oh this is
not this is uncommon but not such a bad
move yeah what you do he kind of
threatens d4
maybe that's not the best but this was
somewhat quickly plate
I am kibitzer him yeah well of what
assume taking is almost automatic but he
doesn't do it
it's a bit odd
what other movies now or do we have some
connection issue he is connected weird
maybe he was thinking about
he had this song I was just just
thinking about it that this could be an
idea so maybe we can get some sort of
Banco style play rolling
the bishop has has a funny piece but it
is I think quite well positioned can
take one g7 if the knight moves on it's
not so easy to move it actually well ok
came 297 if he wants i'm not recapturing
he immediately i wanted wanted to have
this year
I wonder if night a force on Dan yeah
should prevent that problem
this one submission purpose the bishop
but this is a double attack right
d4 was check into pawn on a seven
not too easy now for him finding a good
move here yeah I wanted to mention you
can easily overlook that somehow that's
a full full night yeah sorry followed
rematching but it's um otherwise I
cannot really make the videos in some
sort of fluent way lets him yeah it was
a bit odd that he took so long I thought
taking is like mandatory almost because
why would you want to get your porn
structure wrecked
I mean don't see a reason why you would
do that so you took it deform and then
before I think it's playable at least I
think took it a three I think taking is
quite quite a normal choice yeah Bishop
h6 this is interesting because he now
that's the idea to take my bishop and I
probably have to check on f6 the the
upside of this is that I'm now getting
control over d5 so a bishop for example
would be nicely positioned and this pawn
structure loses dynamism but maybe I
mean the engine is correct and giving
black an advantage here but I don't know
this is also interesting sorry
interesting like here here here okay he
went 97 who takes that yeah and I wanted
to get this Queen a1 on the board and
this is probably not best yeah here it's
a little bit awkward
d5 yeah if I was the means I expected
him to play after which I was thinking
that Nightbeat
is also an interesting choice of course
I can simply take and be okay that's
true but our thoughts would be
interesting there's this I in fact
bishops is six yeah well okay I haven't
I have a maybe enough compensation here
but the outcome this is probably just
better to take him and yeah here it must
be a little something the structure is a
bit favorable for white you can more
easily attack those pawns than like you
too but of course I mean yeah it's it's
a bit of a it's a bit unusual that this
is such a heavy threat Queen Queen in
the corner so it's one of those blunders
that you can somehow understand how it
happens okay thanks for watching